some good news for las vegas ces has
announced
it will return in january one of many
shows in conventions planning a comeback
and those in the industry are just
ecstatic but is southern nevada ready
for this now
surge in demand sasha loftis joining us
now live outside the las vegas
convention center with the latest
denise and bryan those in the industry
are just really excited to get back to
those conventions
they know and love but after the hit our
local economy took over the last year
experts say there could be a few growing
pains
after a year-long hiatus conventions are
coming back to las
vegas a big part of our business is the
convention business
flower shop miss daisy is one of many
local spots
getting ready for an uptick in demand
ramping up my team
and getting my wholesalers in place for
the type of business that is going to be
coming through
while out of town vendors like tuffskin
are planning a return to the valley
new marketing materials we're coming up
with more fun things to engage our
clients
but after months of closures layoffs and
reduced capacity
is our city ready to handle hundreds of
thousands of guests
hopefully this is sort of the the pains
of getting
back up and running principal analyst
jeremy aguero believes the transition
may be tough at first is it going to be
stressful are people going to be asked
to do
you know one person asked to do two jobs
are we going to be deploying
more technology mike that can might the
visitor experience be
affected in some areas yes i mean all
those things are going to take place but
he says
our economy's recent rebound is nothing
but good news
the event industry was probably one of
the hardest hit industries in las vegas
we just have to turn it back on and
those in the industry can't wait for the
excitement
of future trade show demands yeah we're
ready to rock and roll
now world of concrete is the first major
convention slated to take place here
at this new expansion the west hall of
the convention center
that's slated for june of 2021 just
about a month and a half away
it will also be the first to use that
brand new boring tunnel new
transportation system underground
reporting live in las vegas tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now